- When Mark bought Instagram
for a billion dollars
a couple months earlier
I did some Fox program
and I said that, it was
December and they're like,
"Hey, make some
predictions for 2013."
This one, I am predicting that
Facebook acquires Instagram.
15 million users for Instagram,
probably gonna push 30 next year
and I just have this funny
feeling that Zucks is gonna
look at that talent,
look at that app,
bring it in-house.
I was like Facebook's
gonna buy Instagram. Right?
Cool, whatever.
Four months later, it happens.
And CNN asks me to
come on because the video
went a little viral in
the tech community.
So I was on Piers Morgan,
on Piers Morgan's show
his opening line is,
"This company is 550 days old,
"how the hell is it
worth a billion dollars?"
- And my opening line is
they stole it.
I get out of the studio,
I'm hardcore Twitter
so I go on it
and literally there
are thousands of tweets
of people calling
me a fucking idiot.
So literally that night from
10 o'clock at night to
4 in the morning I favorited
every one of those tweets.
By hand, all of them.
(audience laughter)
I think this is a good story
'cause this is what an
entrepreneur I think does.
Favorited them all and then
I guess last year this time,
right, Facebook bought
WhatsApp for $18 billion
and every article the next
day after the news came out
is like oh wait a minute they
fucking stole Instagram.
And no joke, for a week, my wife
and I went to Turks and Caicos
for a weekend, Luckily she likes
just to read and I can't bother
her and I laid on beach
for 19 hours a day,
two days in a row and replied
to every single person
that called me an idiot
and said, "What now, bitch?"
(audience laughter)
(light music)